like I said I'm a divorce I spent my
whole life trying to fight the voice and
strengthen the bond between husband and
wife and I don't know if we're making a
lot of progress there gosh America is
just a littered landscape of broken
marriages broken relationships it's
really sad we're becoming a very lonely
country New York Times reported that 51%
of all women now live alone I mean that
those are frightening statistics that
51% of women now say that they'd rather
be on their own than with a man that
means that they're really giving up on
love they're just you know I'll live my
own life I mean I've tried this it
hasn't worked out I've only gotten
heartache
let's say a couple haven't made love in
a year which is very common one out of
three American couples are platonic so
most people would tell you uh go to a
hotel for the weekend
buy sexy lingerie well what if you're
not even motivated to do that or what if
that's just going through the motions I
mean what I do is I look at the erotic
mind why how can a man be in bed with a
naked woman who's his wife and not feel
excited what changed in his mind in his
view in his perception of her and if we
could alter it back to its original
conditions we can restore the attraction
even they never go to
I was counseling a husband and wife and
I said this wife be nice to your husband
speak to him respectfully did she always
yells at him and puts him down and she
said no way I'm not gonna do that until
he treats me better
I said ser well aside from the fact that
if your boats gonna wait for the other
to start this marriage is gonna
disintegrate I said are you telling me
you'll only do the right thing if
someone gives you an incentive aren't
you supposed to do the right thing no
matter what even if it has no impact
even if it doesn't deserve it it's not
for him it's for you you want to be a
good person don't you you're not
becoming good for him
don't let him make you into a person but
you don't want to